culture ans lille débutera dans quelques
jours pour sa 25e édition l'exposition
d'art contemporain de paris à andrésy
accueille onze artistes sur le thème de
l'envers du décor parmi eux laurent
perbos invité d'honneur l'artiste
plasticien utilise l'objet issus de la
grande consommation comme matière pour
ses oeuvres je vais prendre un objet qui
existe déjà et je vais en déformer une
caractéristique comme le poids la taille
ou la couleur pour que cet objet échappe
aux caractéristiques aux codes qu'on
al'habitude de la tribu et comme ses
prédécesseurs il a été invité à habiller
la façade de la maison du moussel
d'andrésy n fatah bol c'est une oeuvre
in situ réalisés sur place spécialement
pour le bâtiment elle a nécessité près
de quatre jours d'installation et 150
convenable de tailles diverses je vais
essayer de donner l'illusion que le
bâtiment l'édifice est entièrement
rempli de gonflables et qu' il ya une
telle profusion que deux des fenêtres
des gonflables s'en échappe une oeuvre
qui propose deux lectures évocatrice de
la plage mais aussi critique d'une
société de surconsommation objectif
questionner le regard du spectateur au
premier abord assez gai ludique coloré
joyeux et en fait finalement si on
regarde de plus près c'est aussi très
polluants ces issues d'une industrie
pétrochimique avec un indice carbone
très élevé enfin bref voilà tout le plan
vert du propos que c'est censé au
premier abord véhiculer ce support une
opportunité pour l'artiste qui lui
permet de changer ses habitudes
effectivement c'est une belle
opportunité de pouvoir travailler sur un
sur un bâtiment comme ça
d'une part ben moi ça me permet de
déplacer un peu mon travail qui plutôt
prend place dans des galeries ou des
centres d'art donc dans des lieux un peu
clos de murs blancs et là c'est une
réelle opportunité de pouvoir un peu à
être dans une démesure sculptures en
l'île débutera le 13 mai prochain les
oeuvres seront à découvrir jusqu'au 25
septembre